foreign
[Music]
there's only one way to find out
you and I we're not so different agent
Argyle
little help hold on
[Music]
phenomenal sweetie but
what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
cop-out
hey there's a cat in there
oh my God you're Ellie freaking Conway
oh yeah what is it you do Espionage
would you sign my book
here we go
love this book
[Music]
come on
who are these people real life spies why
would they care about me because you're
a goddamn fortune teller really
when you wrote in your new book actually
happened and you Kicked the Hornets test
you didn't even know existed I think
some really big trouble mom
[Music]
I want all assets on them now I need her
to write the next chapter
God I hate that cat
[Music]
it's time for you to meet the real agent
Argyle
oh my God oh my God oh my God